[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم تزامنا مع زيارتي وفد
الوساطه الافريقيه هجوم صاروخي روسي مكثف
على العاصمه كيف ورئاسه الاوكرانيه تصفه
بالاعنف منذ اسابيع وموسكو تؤكد انفتاحها
على بحث خيارات تسويه الازمه وتقول ان
اقتراحات الوفد الافريقي ستبحث خلال لقاء
بوتين بقاده القاره في السابع عشر من
يونيو طائرات الجيش السوداني تقصف مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع الجنوبيه الخرطوم
واشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في ولايه غرب
دارفور قرب الحدود تشاديه في حين تتهم
واشنطن قوات الدعم السريع وحلفائها
بانتهاك حقوق الانسان في الاقليم وتحمل
الجيش مسؤوليه الفشل في حمايه المدنيين
هنا
قبيله زيارتي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
المرتقبه الى بيجين مستشار الامن القومي
للولايات المتحده جيك سوليفان يستبعد
حدوثا فراجا في العلاقات بين واشنطن
وبيجين والخارجيه الصينيه تقول ان ابوابها
مفتوحه دائما للدبلوماسيه وتؤكد ضروره ان
يعالج التواصل مخاوف طرفين بعد ايام من
اسقاط طائره مسيره محمله بنصف كيلو من
المواد المخدره الجيش الاردني يعلن اسقاط
طائره اخرى محمله باسلحه كانت قد انطلقت
من سوريا والقوات المسلحه الاردنيه تؤكد
مضيئها في التعامل بكل قوه وحزم مع اي
تهديد على الواجهات الحدوديه الى اللقاء